bonjour jean marc jancovici bonjour vous
êtes président de the chief project vous
êtes vous avez fondé le cabinet carbone
et vous êtes membre du haut conseil du
climat vous faites partie de ces
écologistes qui disent que le nucléaire
est un moyen d'amortir la décroissance
inéluctable de l'économie liée à la
rareté de l'énergie vous défendez cette
énergie alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a
encore le savoir-faire en france
puisqu'on a on a un peu baissé quand
même la garde dans ce domaine on a eu du
mal à faire le p r par exemple qui coûte
plus cher qu'il ya eu des délais très
rallongé est-ce qu'on a encore le
savoir-faire pour une telle ambition
alors moi qui suis tout petit patron
d'entreprise est par ailleurs
actionnaire enfin coactionnaires de mon
entreprise il ya quelque chose que dans
le monde de l'entreprise on connaît bien
c'est que quand l'actionnaire passe son
temps à dire que les salariés de sa
filiale sont des incompétents nuisible à
un moment ça se ressent sur ce qui se
passe dans la filiale or ça fait à peu
près vingt ans que l'état français a le
nucléaire honteux en gros depuis que
mitterrand a sacrifié superphénix pour
avoir la paix sur le déploiement du
reste du parc est depuis 20 ans on est
dans l'ambiguïté total qui consiste à
dire à et df sept ans on va même ouvrir
vous aider à en faire tout en disant
publiquement que c'est pas terrible ce
que vous faites bon alors quand vous
êtes dans ce genre de contexte
à un moment vous finissez par payer les
pots cassés c'est tout à fait
inéluctable j'ai envie de dire dans
cette affaire là le fait que le jour où
on décide de refaire un réacteur on est
des délais un peu long et des surcoûts
c'est pas étonnant d'abord il faut
rappeler que ce réacteur est un réacteur
franco allemand le p r donc on a mis les
ceintures française avec les bretelles
allemande donc ça vous fait un bouzin un
peu compliqué plus compliquée que ce qui
était utile et nécessaire
la deuxième chose c'est que
effectivement en france ça fait 20 ans
qu'on n'a pas construit de réacteurs
donc encore pour commencer on dépasse le
budget enfin vous savez la tour eiffel a
terminé à trois fois le budget initial
ou deux fois et demie eurotunnel a lui
terminé à cinq fois le budget initial et
n'importe quel déploiement informatique
dans une entreprise ne termine jamais en
dessous du budget initial et le multiple
peut être très élevé donc le fait que
l'on dépasse le coup sûr quelque chose
qu'on recommence à faire ce n'est pas
inquiétant en soi au sens de six ans se
débarrasser de tout ce qui a dépassé un
budget il ya beaucoup de choses dont on
se débarrasserait
compris la filière voulait pas aller pas
atteinte elle a encore la capacité donc
ce que je suis en train de dire juste
c'est que quand on recommence quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas fait depuis
longtemps au surplus sur un modèle neuf
on redémarre on redémarre c'est normal
voilà en plus areva je suis désolé de le
dire mais a fait une erreur stratégique
qui est de monter trois marches à la
fois puisque ils ont voulu faire un
nouveau métier sur un nouveau modèle
dans un nouveau pays puisque le premier
européenne a commencé à être mis en
construction c'était olkiluoto en
finlande et donc ils sont partis dans le
décor mais j'ai envie de dire n'importe
quelle entreprise qui essaye de monter
trois marches à la fois prend un risque
énorme
parce qu'avant il faisait que l'îlot
nucléaire ils sont devenus maîtres
d'oeuvre sa demande de savoir gérer tout
a pas de procédure avec l'autorité de
sûreté qui savait pas gérer tout un tas
de trucs et c'est sa demande de savoir
surveiller des gens qui coule le béton
alors qu'avant ce n'était pas leur
métier enfin bref donc ils ont des
bandages édition il ya des contingences
mais vous passez pour colin crédit les
gens certains on a mis toutes les
chances de notre côté nous pour qu'il en
soit ainsi
c'est juste ça veut dire que d'accord
est ce que ça veut dire que pour autant
on est en train de prendre des risques
avec la sûreté
je ne le crois pas est ce que ça veut
dire pour autant que si on recommence à
faire de la série on fera tous les
opéras 10 milliards de je ne le crois
pas non plus je vais même
raisonnablement prêt à parier mon argent
sur le fait que ça sera pas le cas voilà
donc cessé alors après on a un deuxième
une deuxième tête de série qu'est ce qui
se passe en ce moment en grande bretagne
c'est pareil la grande bretagne ça fait
des années qu'ils n'ont pas construit un
réacteur
donc ils ont aussi perdu la main donc je
là par contre dans le sens inverse je
suis prêt à prendre les paris qu'ils
tiendront pas le budget mais ça ne veut
pas dire encore une fois qu'il faut pas
faire de nucléaire c'est la solution à
vous vous dites que c'est la solution du
pot face à la transition énergétique
c'est la solution moins chère que le
renouvelable et oui ça ça produit plus
donc ça amorti la récession ligue 1 deux
choses la première c'est que aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez de quoi dépend
l'économie mondiale vous constatez qu
elle dépend de son approvisionnement en
combustible fossile ayant en particulier
une courbe que j'aime beaucoup montré
qu'ils montrent que la variation du pib
par personne dans le monde
ça fait maintenant trente ans qu'elle
reflète très exactement je dis bien très
exactement la variation de la production
de pétrole dans le monde en volume car
vous regardez la quantité de tonnes de
pétrole qui sort de terre chaque année
vous faites une courbe sur 7 sur la
variation s'étonne
vous avez très exactement la variation
du pib par personne dans le monde
d'accord
donc vous pouvez jeter à la poubelle
tous les modèles macroéconomiques du fmi
de l'os et des oeufs etc
ils valent pas un clou par contre ça ça
marche très bien pourquoi parce que
l'énergie et en particulier le pétrole
pilote l'économie mondiale parce que ça
pilotes les flux physiques qui peuvent
être échangés entre les usines entre les
usines et les consommateurs entre les
magasins etc
et donc si vous en avez - vous avez
moins dé change donc moins d'économies
point barre et si vous en avez plus vous
augmentez les échanges et vous avez plus
d'économiser vous extrayez plus de
ressources ou alors en marche très bien
or le pétrole il est il a passé son pic
de production sur la partie
conventionnelle
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie a
fini par le dire en décembre dernier à
partir de maintenant sur cette partie là
ça va décliner il reste le pétrole de
schiste aux états unis qui est une
énigme parce que c'est un cash flow
négatif depuis le début et les sables
bitumineux du canada qui sont très chers
et qu'ils ont une grosse pénalité
énergétique d'extraction donc tout ça
est un équilibre instable et à mon avis
bien avant que je meure et probablement
pas plus tard que dans quelques années
tout ça va commencer à descendre en
europe au japon et dans l'essentiel de
la zone ocde et même quelque part aux
états unis ça va contracter
l'approvisionnement énergétique globale
parce que le pétrole est la première
énergie utilisée dans la zone du coup ça
va contracter l'économie dans cette
affaire là vous allez donc avoir de
moins en moins d'argent et pas de plus
en plus si vous voulez remplacer les
fossiles par autre chose il va falloir
utiliser ce qui vous donne le plus de
autre chose par euros investis or le
nucléaire correspond beaucoup mieux à
cette définition que l'éolien et le
solaire parce que l'éolien et le solaire
ne sont pas des solutions complètes
sauf à ce que cette interview n'est pas
lieu quand ya pas de vent et pas de
soleil ce qui est une option mais à ce
moment ça change significativement les
comptes annuels de xerfi
eh bien vous êtes obligés de compléter
ces énergies facettes fourniture
d'électricité intermittente par quelque
chose qui permet de garantir
l'approvisionnement et donc du stockage
et quand vous intégrer le coût du
stockage en plus du solaire et du coût
de production du solaire et de l'éolien
vous vous retrouvez très au-dessus même
avec des hypothèses optimistes du coût
du nucléaire même très cher et vous
voyez pas de progrès technologiques
possibles dans ce domaine que par
ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui vous avez des panneaux qui
coûte pas cher et des éoliennes qui
coûtent pas cher c'est parce que c'est
mondialisée grâce au pétrole donc tous
les panneaux sont faits en chine et
toutes les nacelles
en allemagne que vous avez besoin
d'industrie minière qui fonctionne avec
du pétrole et du charbon que vous avez
besoin de pétrochimie qui fonctionne par
définition avec du pétrole que vous avez
besoin d'industries manufacturières donc
le jour où vous n'aurez plus que des
moulins à vent et des panneaux solaires
pour fabriquer d'autres panneaux
solaires et d'autres éoliennes y compris
faire fonctionner les mines la
métallurgie la chimie les transports etc
tout ça juste avec des moulins à vent et
des panneaux solaires on en reparlera du
coup du mégawattheure mais il va être
multiplié par n'importe quoi lycée sens
économiquement c'est beaucoup plus dur à
gérer c'est ce que le une fois que le
système est complet vous perdez de la
productivité et les cours repartent à la
hausse
donc en fait on comprend pas qu'une fois
que le système est complet et ses
problèmes de tous les modèles
économiques qui valent pas un clou là de
l'ademe et c'est qu'on voit partout ils
font pas le contrôle de cohérence à
l'arrivée mais si vous faites le
contrôle de cohérence à l'arrivée vous
vous rendez compte que ses coûts c'est
juste parce que l'économie est truffé de
combustibles fossiles qu'on arrive à les
avoir
le jour où l'économie n'est plus truffé
de combustibles fossiles ces coûts
explosent et pour vous la filière
nucléaire reste une alternative pour
donc la filière nucléaire vaut moins
cher aideront heureux quand vous
regardez le système complet et virages
ça vaut moins cher
même avec le démantèlement même avec les
déchets mais avec tout ça et l'état de
la cour des comptes a fait des tops
compte qu'ils sont tout à fait public
consultables et c'est donc ça vous
rajoute du 5 % ici du 10% là ça me
change pas les ordres de grandeur et
vous vous rendez compte qu'une fille et
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait du nucléaire
historiquement avant de faire des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires je
signale que les moulins à vent on
connaît ça depuis des siècles donc si
c'était moins cher de faire des moulins
à vent que des réacteurs nucléaires
on aurait installé des moulins à vent
avant d'avoir besoin d'installer des
réacteurs nucléaires c'est parce qu'on a
fait parce qu'en fait c'est plus cher
mais merci jean marc jancovici d'être
venu sur le plateau de herve canal pour
nous exposer ses enjeux